merci elle a besoin retour effectivement
sur le plateau de la vraie vie où l'on
parle du climat social avec nos quatre
invités jean yves caullet député ps de
l'yonne à christian piot
pour la cgc alain suguenot député maire
de beaune qui n'est pas aux 24 heures
mais qui est avec nous et sandrine mois
de la cgt quand même cette semaine il ya
eu des bonnes nouvelles je pense
notamment aux contrats aux contrats
d'ampleur pour chantiers navals de saint
nazaire et surtout à la baisse du
chômage ac le deuxième mois consécutif
la première baisse sur un an depuis 2008
est ce que c'est la politique du
gouvernement qui commence à porter ses
fruits
il fallait écouter en tout cas n'y est
pas étrangère ce serait un petit peu
facile comme ça va mal d'expliquer que
c'est à cause des gouvernements et quand
ça va un petit peu mieux sur certains
indicateurs expliqué que tout ça n'a
rien à voir avec la politique menée donc
je pense qu'on a eu on est effectivement
petit à petit sur des indicateurs macro
économiques qui s'améliorent
je relisais des documents de lui et même
qui n'est pas su suspecte de soutenir le
parti socialiste dire que les marchés
entreprises commençaient à se
reconstituer que l'investissement qui
est porteur d'emplois à terme repart un
petit peu la ffb hier disait qu
effectivement cette année en matière de
bâtiment devait être l'arrêt inflexion
vers détermine donc oui il ya la
politique macroéconomique donne des
premiers résultats maintenant c'est dans
la durée que ça se juge
on est dans un pacte entre est différent
de la situation sociale qu'on évoquait
tout à l'heure sur un projet de loi est
ensuite bien entendu il faut aussi dire
que ce n'est pas que la politique du
gouvernement c'est aussi le contexte
international c'est aussi le travail des
gens sains et qui sont dans les
entreprises c'est aussi les initiatives
des chefs d'entreprise qui petit à petit
porte aussi ce mouvement
on est loin de compte on est loin de
compte mais enfin les efforts demandés
portent un peu de fruits avec des
finances publiques qui par ailleurs bas
sont en meilleur état que quand on a
récupéré le pays dit non pourtant les
chiffres sont là à l'instant je crois
qu'effectivement moi je me réjouis que
la situation puisse s'améliorer parce
qu'effectivement il faut le rappeler sur
les entreprises sont les françaises et
les français qui souffrent il souffre à
nouveau à cause de cette crise
aujourd'hui il n'empêche que c'est bien
sûr la politique y compris la banque
centrale européenne
qui peut être catastrophique à terme
mais qui tend édition cash l'arbre et on
dénoncera concept aujourd'hui où la
large en hélicoptère que vous dit certes
les taux d'intérêt très bas faut que par
définition s'ils savaient pas bien
la france est peut-être le dernier pays
d'europe qui aujourd'hui bénéficient de
ces effets là alors que les planètes
étaient soi-disant signé d'après le
président républicain taux d'intérêt bas
pétrole bas sans doute un peu et puis
euro très bas donc c'est un exemple
pendant lequel on a attendu alors que
les autres ont déjà redémarré nous notre
chômage pour deux mois consécutifs ou
encore le premier mois c'est un
transfert entre les catégories et qui
est terrible mais c'est vrai ce dernier
mois il ya une baisse celle ci est
véritable donc je souhaite que ça
continue
mais c'est certainement pas à cause de
la politique était dans tous les cas des
politiques qui ont été menées par ce que
la logique du des politiques de l'emploi
lui depuis quatre ans on a tellement
modifiait les emplois aidés qui
commencent à porter leurs fruits
mais c'est pas ce qu'on appelait une
inversion de la courbe du chômage ce
presque 700 mille chômeurs de plus en
quatre ans très honnêtement il serait
temps d seixas cesse sinon tu pourras
jamais assumé avec les équipes qui
seront donc aujourd'hui très honnêtement
ça ne va pas mais qui oublient cela ne
va pas mieux pour tout le monde
je souhaite enlever qu'accomplissent
réussir ensemble parce que moi je fais
partie des parlementaires qui croient
que la france doit réussir même si c'est
pas le gouvernement que j'appelle de mes
voeux
il n'empêche que on est encore les
derniers de la classe j'espère qu'on va
s'en sortir à secret story
christian pinon santé dans les enfants
parce que ça commence à c'est allé mieux
c'est assez difficile certaines
entreprises qui effectivement regarder
un petit peu leur carnet de commandes
donc pour l on pourrait dire que ça va
mieux globalement je pense que ça reste
quand même assez morose et je suis plus
en tant que cfe-cgc on attend un petit
peu les mois qui viennent pour se faire
une philosophie sur une reprise réelle
de
de l'activité économique et sur un stade
à mieux pour l'instant on est assez
assez dubitatif ça va peut-être aller
mais ça va peut-être aller mieux mais on
en est pas encore complètement persuadé
par contre ce qu'on a constaté c'est
qu'effectivement un certain nombre
d'entreprises avaient bénéficié
davantage de la part du gouvernement
ce qu'on ose espérer c'est que si
effectivement le sa famille proche se
concrétise ses avantages auront une
répercussion sur les salaires parce que
je pense que tu arrêtes si les salaires
augmentent un petit peu si les salariés
se sentent mieux dans leur peau
je pense que la morosité ambiante
disparaîtra et que l'activité économique
reprendra effectivement on était une
transition pour son vrai parce que je
vous entends encore ici sur ce plateau
critiqué les 40 milliards dead et de
cadeaux aux entreprises finalement ça a
l'air partout en france je les ai déjà
dit en bourgogne franche comté en
bourgogne pardon du cluzet mois en 2015
les entreprises ont touché 1,2 milliard
d'êtres public sur trois dispositifs 6e
pas que de responsabilité et allègements
de cotisations et en 2015 c'était six
mille demandeurs d'emploi
supplémentaires 1,2 milliard c'est
l'équivalent du budget de la grande
région bourgogne franche comté
donc ça peut nous interroger ça doit
interroger les salariés et nos
organisations syndicales mais y compris
y compris les responsables politiques
où est passé cet argent parce que ça
fait quand même cher et entendent lui si
ça fait quand même cher l'emploi
ça fait comme chalon pour moi je me suis
dit encore monsieur gattaz pour le pacte
de responsabilité avait trouvé un
million d'emplois
alors certes ça va mieux il ya des
marges d'entreprise qui ce qui se
reconstruise oui mais excusez moi moi je
suis représentant d'une organisation
médicale et donc des salariés ça va
mieux pour qui pas mieux pour les
salariés en terme d'emploi effectivement
le bois dernier l'allègement la baisse
du taux de chômage de catégorie à ce
transfert est sûre les catégories b et c
dire des travailleurs pauvres des
salariés qui travaillent moins de 78
heures ou un peu plus de son 18h ce sont
des travailleurs pauvres c'est à dire
qu'on l'emploi va mieux mais ce sont des
salariés qui ont à peine de quoi vivre
at à peine de quoi finir leur mois et en
terme de salaire est là je suis d'accord
avec vous en terme de salaire les
salaires stagnent voire diminuent pour
une catégorie de salaires
donc ça va mieux peut-être mais nous on
aimerait aussi que ça aille mieux pour
les salaires parce qu augmenter les
salaires
c'est aussi augmenté les carnets de
commandes augmenter le pouvoir d'achat
c'est augmenter la consommation et on
sait que 50% de la croissance dépend de
la consommation des ménages
donc voilà non ça va mieux peut-être
mais nous ce qu'on veut c'est au perche
à l'arrivée faut que l'argent public
l'été distribuer aux entreprises
bénéficient aussi aux salariés qui
créent les richesses de ce texte sera
pas mieux pour nos agriculteurs ça a pas
mieux pour nos artisans dont colonna on
parle bien sûr de l'entreprise mais je
crois qu'il ya des secteurs entiers
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont très très mal et
qui ne voient pas non plus la sortie du
tunnel et je pense que les mesures qui
sont prises ne vont pas dans ce sens ça
non plus malgré tout le moral des
français est en hausse
pas si vous avez vu d'étude de l'insee
donc c'était hier c'est l'indicateur le
plus haut niveau sont et atteint son
plus haut niveau par n'ont jamais
atteint depuis 2005 cette union par
contre par rapport à la situation de la
france chacun se dit après tout moi je
me sens pas mal
n'oubliez pas que la france compte tenu
du statut de la fonction publique n'a
pas véritablement mis empêche black la
cgt dit le contraire mais pour le privé
certainement l'austérité mais pour le
public n'a pas une véritable street est
donc aujourd'hui illustre le parti ceci
si cet amortisseur qui permet dans cette
vision dans les situations de crise
peut-être d'éviter le pire
mais il n'empêche que pour tous les
autres aujourd'hui c'est une catastrophe
c'est ça qui explique que ce hiatus
entre le fait que finalement le moral
des français ça a l'air d'aller
mais n'ont pas confiance quand même en
leur gouvernement mais pas parce que
sous les eaux on passe notre temps comme
un petit peu comme si on était intoxiqué
par des photographies à décrire des
choses qui évoluent dans le temps ce qui
est ce qui vient d'être dit sur l'effet
des mesures en faveur des marges des
entreprises sur les salaires est exact
il est exact que les faits on souhaite
sur un renouveau de des carnets de
commandes et de l'activité économique
c'est aussi un effet sur les salaires et
sur l'emploi c'est évident simplement on
peut pas avoir neuf sans avoir de poules
si vous permettez cette expression on a
choisi on a choisi une politique de
reconstitution des marges d'ajustement
des cotisations en pensant que cela
allait permettre une meilleure
compétitivité et un retour de l'emploi
et on espère aussi que sa puce les
bouchers sur une revalorisation des
salaires
on a la chance d'avoir une inflation
faible
ce qui fait que le pouvoir d'achat est
moins impactés par des mesures de
stabilisation salariale que si nous
étions en inflation fort il ya eu un
petit geste de fait sur le point
d'indicé de la fonction publique qui
montre bien qu'on est dans cette
gradation dans cette étape de commencer
à avoir des effets d'une politique et
d'une politique de redressement des
comptes publics dont je souligne qu'elle
porte ses fruits qu'elle est faite par
l'effort des français et qu'elle est
faite en maintenant nos grands systèmes
de solidarité issue du conseil national
de la résistance c'est cet équilibre là
qui effectivement peut apparaître main
chatoyant que des grands soirs où des
grands coups de barre à gauche et à
droite mais qui tient le pays
quant à la comparaison moi j'ai un ami
qui m'a dit tu te rends compte en
espagne le chômage baisse et pas chez
nous oui son parti de 24%
on reste en bresse dans un taux de
chômage trop élevé
bien sûr il commence à être grignoté
mois ou ces deux mois ces deux mois
j'attends sur la durée qu'on voit si on
est dans une danse dans une vraie
dynamique mais je considère qu'il faut
pas en même temps dire tout va bien et
on suppose que le président va dire ça
va mieux ça ne va pas bien et ça n'ira
pas très bien tout de suite demain matin
mais on peut voir si on est dans la
bonne direction pas moi c'est ce que
j'espère sont les salaires je crois que
les perspectives ne sont pas
encourageantes puisque on voit bien il
ya les livres sessions annuelles
obligatoires dans les entreprises dans
les entreprises du privé et les
informations qui nous remontent ne sont
pas franchement encourageante bien au
contraire
toutes les entreprises malgré les aides
qu'elles reçoivent
malgré l'augmentation de leur chômage
toutes les entreprises grignote les
augmentations de salaire à la halle et
grignote c'est la plupart du temps les
négociations annuelles obligatoires
comment sur du 02 01 12 02 vous imaginez
sont les salariés eux mêmes des salariés
qui s'investit dans les entreprises même
des salariés qui sont prêts à fin des
heures supplémentaires parce qu' ils
soutiennent leur entreprise les premiers
à défendre une boîte quand elle femmes
sont les salariés ont droit j'ai pas vu
le meeddat de vente r w quand il a fermé
un camp j'ai bien vu des salariés
défendent leur emploi et donc ils sont
ce qu'ils lisent qui les exaspère c'est
qu'ils sont des efforts il s'investit
ses salariés ils ont une conscience
nationale résultat c'est niet sur les
salaires et voire même et là je
reviendrai au projet de loi est bien soi
disant pour sauvegarder la compétitivité
des entreprises m'envoie nous on va vous
demander des efforts supplémentaires
ils n'en peuvent plus les salariés ils
veulent avoir ils veulent avoir un
retour des richesses qu'ils créent c'est
le coût du travail le salaire tout le
monde est d'accord pour dire qu'on peut
redonner du pouvoir de charles le prince
et les charges sociales
c'est qu'aujourd'hui tant que système
sera aussi vicié paris d'abord qui sur
tout à l'heure l'amortisseur fonctionne
mais à quel prix au prix bien évidemment
des flics des entreprises et surtout
effectivement ça bloque le mauvais sens
inverse
donc il est temps qu'une alternance dans
ce pays puisse dire clairement les
choses au lieu de monter des usines à
gaz y compris de distribuer 40 milliards
d'août à l'heure d'une manière un peu
particulière sans clivé rythme en retour
il faudrait peut-être d'une manière plus
simple décidé purement et simplement de
bcc charles et de trouver tva sociale
world race de trouver les voyages au
vietnam en raison d'une spin-off travaux
qui auraient mis moins de la conclusion
qu'est ce qui fait que ça ira mieux
vraiment en quelques secondes les
salaires alors le dirait si l'ensemble
des salariés aux retrouves du pouvoir
d'achat comme le disait madame il est
clair que le pouvoir d'achat et la
consommation en général à une part
importante dans la situation économique
du pays
donc il est clair que si on recrée du
pouvoir d'achat quelque part à travers
les salaires ou à travers un autre
système mais j'ai rien à vous proposer
il est clair que la situation économique
s'améliorera et le moral des français
est également merci merci merci à tous
d'avoir participé à cette émission je
vous rappelle que vous pouvez revoir ce
débat sur notre site internet vous
pouvez france 3 point fr la semaine
prochaine nous vous proposerons une
émission en commun avec france en
franche-comté dès 11 heures une émission
qui sera consacré à la répartition des
rôles entre dijon et besançon puisque
vous savez le conseil régional doit
rendre son avis d'ici le 24 juin
notamment sur l'emplacement de l'hôtel
de région pour la recette du pastis
poursuit très bel après-midi à tous
à